[Music]
and I'm watching you news watching you I
hope not
or you're watching us I'm watching you
right there I hope you're watching me
kurotsuchi submitted by salmon belly
please no exist doesn't even exact it's
coming back on it wasn't under
mainlander maintenance so we have to go
those clothes I need to come back for
the games go back it's not very good
anymore but we should go back for we
should go back to meme for the memes
Thanks yeah a Japanese hotel has
apologized for bedsider system robots
that allowed video and sound to be hat
oh man I'm sorry what are you my allowed
allowed it's not on a billboard whoever
wants a hack it come on in so you could
hack it and make it like play whatever
sound you want it no I think you can
record the people that are inside the
room so I'm imagining if it's what I
think it is so if it's robot people from
other servers they can log on to the
server and then go for me good play and
then they can just like tap into the
robot and just like or whatever you log
into the robot and then you can have
like it's one of those robots what do
you mean one of those robots and then
it's a wild night here on out I don't
know if I'd want to log into their
Japanese Han na hotel bed now who's
owned by the HIAS group is a hotel
staffed by robots oh and guess can be
checked in by humanoids okay and
reception bots are there to wait before
you even enter your room there is a
facial recognition that you need to go
through so the whole thing I think the
whole hotel is just themed as like a
futuristic robotics hotel so I even need
facial recognition to get in and then
there is a bedside robot that assists
you with other things which I assume has
the facial recognition as well and then
are there a few of these in Japan
villages Allah it is Japan
I've heard about the ones that give you
room service I they come with like yeah
and like everything is just robots you
don't even deal with humans at all I
ever heard of once inside the hotel room
yeah I don't like that I don't want them
inside my room
apparently this only be there when I
call you has a bedside robot best issue
with other requirements it's a cuz
there's a loose term that's what it says
in the arm oh it's loose I assume though
the robot like I don't know you need a
glass of water or no helpful it's scary
good that be though if it wasn't in hand
with that sir
cuz like to turn on the light we have
like Google lights now and [ __ ] you know
what I mean so let you go but apparently
several weeks ago a security researcher
okay probably a hacker a hired actor
revealed on Twitter that he tried
contacting HIAS group because they
actually had like a unsigned or I assume
unregulated code in their system which
had a tag and it allowed people to
actually access the robot Ving history
any streaming app any streaming out yep
so allowed hackers to use a streaming
app because it had a certain code that
made it you your streamers or hackers
are a longer than Netflix watch this is
also a Jamie because it's also used as a
security system so they could record if
someone tried to like break into the
room that way they could have like the
face so it makes sense that there'd be
essential yeah for them so I guess this
code was it's also secured and regulated
or unsigned or I guess it sounds like
some kind of loophole is somehow
loophole code and the hacker said he did
it he only reviewed it to the public on
Twitter because the hotel group didn't
would not listen after a few weeks till
the exact code and everything I think
he's like hey guys thank you probably
just brought up that it's a thing that
he could do that he said he brought the
hack public after he did not hear back
from notice that's the whole county
realized is it that makes sense though
because in most of time these
corporations they won't respond until
like you bring it out to like the public
yeah so yeah yeah that's why anyone
who's like staying in their there at the
moment they're just like chillin
just like reportedly said you could
access the cameras and microphones and
even the robot remotely [ __ ] [ __ ] up
dude
you're watching listen to anybody in the
room like that also he said that's why
they listed him as cyber see how many
people do you watch and listen to before
he made it public like the guy who
discovers it and just be like I'm going
to say that I discovered it next Friday
this is where the sketchy part comes in
because shortly after obviously the
hotel issued an apology and said they
have fixed the vulnerability I would
hope so but they a cyber security expert
also said like it's not surprising any I
see anything that's connected to the
Internet
yeah is vulnerable to being hacked this
is why I'm like why do you keep putting
[ __ ] what do you like they would like my
Google home every room I keep it in the
kitchen like when I'm cooking I want to
turn on music or I want to check a time
I put on the timer I have mine in my
room so that's why I employed I took it
out of my bedroom now though they have
the switches on them like no it's not
it's I don't have the one with the like
I can run it it's just the audio but I'm
like I don't need them listening I mean
there is still a switch to switch with
audio tool to turn off the mic I can see
your reservation about that I can see
your reservation about that that's what
they want I just like it too much well
I'm pretty sure it didn't work someone
would have been like this doesn't work
oh yeah you know break it apart there
are people who make these until someone
finds out a workaround switches work
manually right yeah I don't
circuits are completed
Google home is so convenient because
there are times it is very convenient no
just in bed and I'm so comfortable and
the light switch is so farm like Google
the lights please and it just turns off
I'm like cool I get to stay my cuddle
position I don't have to move I'm just
interested relaxing
that's what hackers are here for if they
listen that you have be lazy please I'm
gonna say this is why you don't wake up
until like noon yeah cuz you don't have
to do it
what crazy things are happening here
she's like go get boba it's just between
her and Nelson's Nelson is just like you
know wake up under all the clothes no he
did that [ __ ] all I just remembered that
he do like hot laundry I mean I'll sleep
feels like oh so hot you guys like yeah
bit cold and you put like hot yo you
know what I do if you microwave your
socks okay I've done it with rice too
you have a hot pad yeah yeah I've never
just got been like I got Lux what Josh
is done is is washing and drying your
blanket at doing all your bedsheets and
then just taking it out a jar and laying
and ice it's nice or or have you all
like done laundry and like changed into
like hot boxers don't I don't like a hot
rod you ever like a cold day it's pretty
comfy throwing that on but we start
there
you ever do laundry and draw in the bed
and you're like I'm tired I don't know
fold anymore not even when it's hot all
the time nine out of ten times sometimes
you wake up this under it I don't
sometimes I don't push it away I just
sleep on top of it and then I wake up
and I like try like fold and I take up a
t-shirt it's all crinkled all like I
don't want to move the laundry on my bed
so I'll just sleep on the floor
you have like the side-table that you
fold you step on the floor or pushing
you close to the floor sleeping on the
floor is pretty comfy yeah it's pretty
cool I particularly enjoy the floor when
I'm drunk are you drunk most the time
you do girl on a midnight you have the
option yeah I've come home sometimes
after getting you know dropped off by my
uber and I'm like coming in like super
[ __ ] drunk and being like this floor
and I just like kind of like lay down
I'm like I like this right I don't want
I feel the bed and the bed is not the
same I want to sleep on the floor and
then I wake up and my necks all [ __ ]
up and if you have carpet or do you have
just like hard okay so you're like bed
na [ __ ] floor [ __ ] did you drink
anything will be comfortable like if you
think more comfortable it's a guilty
pleasure of sleeping on the floor yeah
looks to achieve or Rylan you need a
Sleep Number just to different profiles
oh this is my drunk sleeping that's
expected I don't know do you know you're
on a fancy but you have the big foam bed
thing that's a fancy bed yes I guess it
is how fancy we're talking sleep numbers
think numbers pretty fancy that's
expenses so these are all done on love
hotels this cyber security extra it's
kind of on top Bigelow Ryan's I'm
playing things you notice in many of
these incidents these devices these
manufacturers do powered do not provide
the ability to turn off the device
it's almost they encourage you to keep
it on 24/7 yeah which he says is
sacrificing security as a result because
I saw that information to other
companies like hey keep it on 24/7 just
in case you're too lazy to roll out of
bed to turn on the lights
yeah thank God you had your Google home
plugged in the thing is they make you
sign papers that say hey we're gonna
sign your information away but because
no one really reads like the terms and
conditions they just say yes just you're
pretty much [ __ ] as soon as like
everything goes out as you buy I also
say all this like paranoid stuff about
Google home but
I have a phone like everyone who's got a
phone like just see anything they're
listening to it and honestly like if you
want to see me watching Disney Plus and
watching all Disney Channel movies I by
all means for watching Gordon Ramsay
yell at people like we're disney plus
things yeah like Disney plus plus doing
anything illegal like like man this guy
really likes Johnny tsunami it's the
only reason why I got to feel good
this guy really likes pup n suds yeah
exactly you coming there's gonna be
video essays playing just like at least
I don't think any of us have like a
cipher like I don't know this is a disc
for like I don't think we have any lives
that are like that interesting worth
watching
yeah just talking about all the drugs
you've been counting for the cartel a
serie that right now hey Siri I mean
that only series not available whose
makes a thing hey Siri try it now you
gotta try it
Oh what am I saying ask Siri how many
was the hounds in a queue oh yeah hey
Siri how many pounds of weed in a kilo
what you doing four kilo I don't know I
don't know if you I don't know I
Kratos believe you only have an ounce or
a pound but how many pounds are in a
kilo it's a lot of pound in tequila
actually I think it's 2.2
[Music]